you can't really call me a crazy Kelly
I'm obsessive I would rather have 800
cats in another man I don't need a man
in my life been there done that bought
the t-shirt new this is called the
cathouse on the Kings it's a 12-acre no
cage no-kill sanctuary rescue Adoption
Center and we also do a lot of space and
neuters oh come here cricket come on
we have close to 800 adults and 300
kittens on the property as we speak it
wasn't like I planned hey I think I'll
have a thousand cats what a novel idea
it wasn't like that
I thought well there's always room for
more they're gonna kill this one we have
way too many cats so this this was my
house you can see that it's an extremely
large house so you had to give up your
home for these paths I tried for about
16 years to make it work but it wasn't
okay having 60 something in my bedroom
one night they threw up in my ear and
that was when I moved all 4,200 square
feet is theirs that's why we call it the
cat house we have saved over 28,000 cats
in 24 years we have a staff now of about
45 you have to be very on top of the job
because you have a lot of cats you're
responsible for no point in rescuing
them and taking them in if you can't
take care of them
you know this is not normal people would
after a while would say well you know I
think I've done this enough I think I'll
go have a life now I think I'll go
travel nope not me yeah
look this way yeah come on I want you to
be on TV